Canon EOS R6 Mark II with the 135 1.8 as
well I had some brief hands on time with
it uh yesterday at the time that you're
watching this video and I I got to tell
you guys honestly speaking this is going
to be a hard camera to pass up for a lot
of you out there that are looking for a
camera between that two thousand to
three thousand US dollar range this
might be the camera you're gonna have to
pick up for a video and also for
photography I walked away really
impressed with unfortunately uh because
of the situation we had a pre-production
camera in the office I was not able to
extract any photos from my session I was
only allowed to touch it basically
inside the office and really outside by
the balcony at Canon's office here in
Singapore let's talk about the build
quality design and the performance it
looks very reminiscent of the original
R6 but there are some more physical
buttons and dials on this case in point
there's a physical switch to switch from
video to photo mode I love this I hated
how they had implemented before they go
into the info and touch this and touch
that it was too many steps Canon has
simplified this they started doing this
already previously with other camera
systems out there but now they've
brought it to the R6 Mark II and it's
fantastic also on the on and off switch
you now have a lock option as well I
like that so you don't knock anything in
your bag it's secure the evf is exactly
the same as the original R6 as well as
the rear display on it so there's no
changes in that way and you only have
two UHS two card slots there is no CF
Express type B which is a little
unfortunate but to Canon's credit
they've been able to maximize the
performance with uhs2 to the point that
we're now getting the fastest Burst Mode
out of any Canon EOS R system right now
40 frames per second and that is coming
in with aura and jpeg with AE and AF
tracking all that is included with 40
frames per second now are we going to
get any sort of rolling shutter versus
the R3 they said the R3 is still better
in that regard but you are going to be
able to shoot more frames per second I
have not been able to test this out I
will do that in the full review when we
get a review unit but I can tell you
just in my brief Hands-On it's pretty
impressive I would say it's kind of on
par with the R5 so if you're going to
shoot sports with the R5 and you're
happy with that then I think you'll be
very happy with this R6 Mark II in terms
of the electronic shutter speed this
24.2 megapixel sensor they are saying it
is different than the R3 the resolving
power is very impressive now part of
that credit goes to the RF lenses and I
was trying the 135 1.8 and the 24105
which is an older lens but the 135 is a
fantastic lens for portraiture I'll talk
about that later on but the resolving
power out of this sensor looked around
35 36 megapixels thereabouts it was
really impressive I'll show you some
sample images that kind of provided for
me in terms of cropping and yeah this is
what exactly what I was seeing as well
with the images I was taking today and
if you want to see these images on a
beautiful display check out the Asus at
fold right here this video is brought to
you by Asus introducing the Wolves first
17-inch OLED foldable screen the Asus
Zenbook 17-fold OLED features six modes
of using the laptop including laptop
mode tablets mode and desktop mode it
offers a laptop experience like no other
with its big and beautiful 17.3 inch
affordable OLED Nano Edge touch screen
and transforms into a portable 12.5
Powerhouse laptop when folded great for
productivity enthusiasts the auto
focusing system has improved they've
added a lot to the system actually more
than we're seeing out of other Canon
cameras so I'm guessing there will be a
firmware update in the near future for
the R5 again maybe or for the R3 but uh
yeah you can track Planes Trains
Motorcycles Cars all that stuff and now
with planes you can actually track the
cockpit yes it will lock onto the
cockpit as the plane's flying which is
interesting so they gave us a sample
image of let's say an airliner plane
taking off and I was a little bit like
wouldn't it be better with a fighter jet
because I think that's where you would
really see that come into play but yes
it does do that as well also it does
track horses now horses and we'll show
you some sample footage of what that
looks like now again I cannot vouch if
this box is exactly or this has been a
little bit of di done to the focusing
box on around it but I will tell you
based on my limited time with the camera
this is kind of how I performed but if
there was no horses in the office but I
will say in terms of tracking this is
kind of what it looked like eye tracking
you can actually assign which eye you
wanted to lock on left right or Auto let
it do its thing and I like this a lot
because this is something I had an issue
with the R3 when I was trying it out
with some MMA fighting I found it was
always switching eyes it was whatever I
was closest to the camera and sometimes
you don't want that so I appreciate that
they've now added this into the R6 Mark
II also what I do like too is if you
just want to like say I don't want to
select I just want it to be automatic
and whatever it sees it focuses on
there's a mode for that as well so Canon
has really beefed up the autofocusing
system inside this camera to the point
where I would arguably say you know Sony
and Canon are neck and neck with a7r5
their new auto focusing system and
they're kind of deep learning AI you're
getting that same technology into the
Canon R6 Mark II so it's going to be a
battle royale between which is gonna be
the better autofocus and I'm going to
tell you it's a really close call this
camera is damn impressive and now in
terms of color science this is a tricky
one because you know everybody likes
Canon colors but you know skin tones can
have a little bit of a magenta look to
them but when I was shooting with this
R6 Mark II it didn't have that it had a
more warm more realistic color to the
image so I did ask the representatives
if there was a difference in terms of
color science now they would not confirm
nor deny if there were any changes but
they say Canon's always improving things
but I can tell you what this looked
really good on skin tones especially
Asian skin tone so if you're worried
about that do not be now let's talk
video for a second you can record up to
6K 60p out by HDMI to your animus ninja
5 ninja 5 plus you can do that now but
in terms of recording internally it is
4K 60 no crop hey guys Bobby from the
future 4K 60 without crop up to 40
minutes of record time 4K 60 with crop
up to 50 minutes of record time no crop
in 4k up to 30p and no crop in full HD
now back to the video now I don't know
who would record 4K 60 for 40 minutes
and beyond that but that is the limit
education outside of that they have
improved the heat management system in
the camera so 4K 30 4K 24
25p it doesn't matter you can record
until the card runs out there's going to
be no overheating warning so that's
something they did tell me about and
something they were very proud to talk
about so again haven't tested it but
here in Singapore we can really take it
through its Paces because it's hot and
humid here year round those reviewers in
Canada they're freezing their ass off
right now us we're sweating our asses
off so we'll test it and we'll let you
know how it performs in heat especially
here in Singapore in addition to that we
got the new multi-function hot shoe to
this so that works without some of the
new speed lights so if you want to use
that that is now implemented you got 5G
connectivity there's a lot of little
things in this camera that are really
interesting but I'm just kind of
highlighting some of the bear points
that it came out as I was talking and
experiencing this camera in the office
for about an hour I will tell you guys
if you're in the market for a Canon R
series camera
and you were thinking about an R6 hold
off
look at this camera because this is
going to give you a lot more for your
buck and I think you're going to really
be happy with it now let's talk about
this all new 135 1.8 we don't know when
this lens is going to launch exactly
they're making an announcement today but
I will tell you I used it I was not
allowed to share images from it again
because it was a pre-production lens
according to them but it was beautiful
but it is a beast of a lens coming
around 996 grams it's heavy it's a thick
it's a big boy it's got a image
stabilization inside the lens you've got
custom function buttons around the lens
so you can assign it to be whatever you
want to be especially for focusing or
not
um but it is heavy on the R6 it is
definitely front heavy I would recommend
possibly getting a battery grip if you
want to use this more long term but I
think for portrait photographers out
there wedding photographers that you
want a beautiful fall off of beautiful
bokeh man it just it is Sublime how this
lens performs and the subject at 1.8 is
tack sharp or even if you shoot animals
and you want something with a 1 35 focal
length and you want that beautiful bokeh
this is a lens you need to seriously
consider I walked away surprise but it
is a heavy lens okay so keep that in
mind the new speed light the el5 this is
kind of in the same categories the 600dx
they're about this is a really nice
speed light but it is quite heavy now in
terms of quality of light this is
absolutely beautiful I gotta I gotta add
it to Canon on this I mean it's a heavy
sucker but it really produces some
beautiful light up to 60 meters in
distance of course you can use it as a
modeling light as well if you're
shooting video you know it's quite
expensive it's an investment for a speed
light out there but if you use this for
your work your Advanced photographer
wedding photographer or you just want an
additional light source if you're
shooting outside you got to consider
this thing however there is a butt to
this you cannot use it with the R5 Canon
considers the R5 and older camera in the
system and it's not updated to take
advantage of this new lighting system
from the speed light so R3 R7 R6 Mark II
these newer cameras can maximize this
the R5 five no are we gonna get an R5
Mark II we got an R6 Mark II and the R6
came out the same time as the R5 Canon
wouldn't tell me that but I have a
feeling an R5 Mark II may be coming out
sooner than we think if the improvements
I'm seeing this R6 Mark II go into an R5
Mark II there's gonna be a lot of these
cameras being sold a lot anyway those
are my initial Impressions on the R6
Mark II let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below are you looking
to pick this up any other questions you
have I will try to answer them for you
we will be getting this camera for a
full review in the near future it goes
on sale November 18th we should get a
camera around there give us a couple
weeks to test it out and we'll get a
video to you as soon as possible with
that guys take care stay safe subscribe
to the channel and I will chat to you
soon by the way you want to see more of
our camera reviews check out with these
videos right here
foreign